i have something that i'd like to share
with you and then maybe
you have some uh just hear your own
thoughts about it
so a long time friend of mine
uh since we're like babies pretty much
known each other
and you know we've grown apart and we've
grown for good reasons and
since then you know he's been like
dealing drugs and
pretty much a bad path so
recently like within the past several
weeks he got in a car crash uh
cops he had a bunch of you know illegal
stuff on him
and uh he got out of court uh you know
he he
basically got away scot-free and uh you
know his response is you know i'm not
gonna really change what i'm doing i
like what i'm doing even though i was
so close to to uh you know being put in
the way
he's just you know i'm just trying to be
happy you know i'm just trying to be
happy i want to hear your
thoughts on that sort of line because
it's kind of like
let me ask you this did you read my book
yeah i'm uh i'm finishing the amazon
book and yours will be next okay so you
haven't read it yet so fire fire fast
high or slow is in is in the book it's
one of the chapters
and um when you get through the book
you'll understand it but basically
it doesn't matter if you share dna with
somebody it doesn't matter if they've
been afraid
friends since you're a baby these are
the [ __ ] like [ __ ] stories that
we tell ourselves as men like we like to
complicate our lives and then justify
why
i'm gonna complicate my life by letting
this loser be in my life because i've
known him since we were babies
even though he's a [ __ ] train wreck
and everything he does invites chaos
into his life which
which means at some point he's going to
bring chaos into your life because
you're friends with them
like you have to hire hire people slowly
meaning invite them into your life
slowly invite women into your life
slowly
take your time to vet them see what
they're all about and as soon as they
show you who they are and if they're a
piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] fire them fast man apprentice
style
give him the cobra like [ __ ] donald
trump did you're fired boom just like
that get the [ __ ] out of here
you have to though right on chaos that's
just like but but dude like that's a
skill that's hard for guys to learn
just like it's hard for guys to learn to
stop simping for women just like it's
guys
you know guys have a hard time um you
know learning not to put themselves in
the friend zone with women i know that
these aren't really problems that you
have but
this is a difficult pill for most guys
to swallow like
oh really you know i have to set
boundaries with people i've known since
i was a baby
well that's a novel concept you know
yeah that's real tough especially when a
lot of your friends
i mean gosh i hate to be that person but
they're just like
doesn't matter dude i mean quite frankly
you don't owe anybody [ __ ]
losers let me just say this again you
don't owe anybody i do not
and and if you let these losers into
your inner circle and you let them stay
there
you will be inviting chaos into your
life the level of chaos you know
can be on a scale of one to [ __ ] 10
with 10 being like ballistic and
possible nuclear levels sort of [ __ ] and
one being very basic
but you will be inviting chaos into your
life by letting these losers into them
gotta listen to a man i uh this is a i
had a hard time with this too dude a
real hard time with this i had a lot of
loser friends growing up
guys doing time and stuff right for
different things
so i totally get what you're saying and
and then even i
i hate to say this because i don't mean
to disparage my the veteran community
or whatever but i get a lot of guys who
come out of combat war zones
that are kind of messed up they got a
lot of issues instead of being willing
to fix or solve those problems
they'd rather collect a check and
continue to have issues right
i don't have time for that i can't have
those people around me
because they're going to suck me into
their situation
and and there's an opportunity cost the
biggest
thing that you have to recognize is
there's an opportunity cost
for how you spend your time and energy
so if you're in a rich is like saying
that all
over the place in different ways it's
like you know
when you spend your time and energy on
somebody that especially that someone is
not demonstrating a capability
of being able to do better it's taking
that time energy of money and flushing
it down the toilet
and that's stuff that doesn't go into
the things you need to be working on to
make yourself better dude
it really is okay so i'd like i like to
add to that
uh so when you say like
for the phrase uh higher slow fire fast
when you say five fast you mean just
like completely like
gone like childhood like all that you
know you could say
uh let me ask you this question would
you would you invite
would you invite a fat single mom with
three kids in tow from three different
fathers into your life yes
oh i mean i know i know paul would but
what about you know that answer
the answer is what no right of course
not no that's
obvious yeah okay so yeah so why would
you let a guy that's a [ __ ] train
wreck that gets into a car crash it's
into drugs that like you know
invites chaos into his life into your
inner circle
it's it's it's no different if you're
willing to set boundaries
with with women you need to be willing
to set boundaries with other people too
i know what you're saying though like at
a distance that's what i'm about to say
yeah like you basically lose your phone
number
right yeah like they're still around
you're not going to tell them to go
pound sand sort of thing but yeah you
just don't
respond to them they text you
you have to have this big moment with
them where they sit them down you know
it's just like
you just put your time and energy
elsewhere like i have a friend for
example great friends from childhood
he is at the bar probably every night if
i run him into in the bar
hey man we do a shot it's cool how you
been awesome bro like sweet
i'm busy with my stuff man you're busy
when you're thinking cool
whatever and i go about my life right
there's no animosity there
it's just that my time and energy gets
focused elsewhere
and that's that's that's all it is you
know you don't have to abandon people
because i know that's what you're
thinking
and there's that i mean i get it i i get
it you know
but they have to demonstrate the
capability to be into your world your
frame you know what i mean
and if they're doing if they're not
demonstrating that capability then
they're just going to suck you down if i
was putting a lot of time and energy
into the guy who hangs out at the bar
every day
i couldn't do what i'm doing right now i
absolutely could not
i could not nurture my business and take
things in the direction
i'm going but i don't have to have a big
moment with him either you know i just
kind of
point in another direction now maybe
someday he's building the business and
he says hey man
i'm building this business doing some
stuff i understand the work you're
trying to do too
whatever let's talk about that okay cool
like that's fine then right it depends
you just got to decide if they're going
to be a toxic force or not and then just
kind of let them
go that way you know what i mean i have
um i have a short video clip uh that i
posted to twitter i'm trying to dig it
up because
hype fury posts so much for me now um of
snoop dogg
explaining this very concept with people
in your life that
just don't make the cut um
i'm gonna i'm gonna keep looking for i
will find it because i know it was in
the last three or four weeks i just have
to keep scrolling and scrolling until i
find a damn thing but
it it it exemplifies the point very very
well
and it'll make complete sense to you uh
just give me a second here
all right look at you let's do a quick
comment yeah go ahead oh i was gonna say
so quick
oh go ahead go ahead lebowski go ahead
sorry
does that go double for family
just because you share dna it doesn't
change anything
yeah it's the same man it's just the
same i i'll tell you how bad it was me
not wanting to
you know abandon my friends and all that
stuff i've given away a cadillac before
i gave i let it do borrow my cadillac i
haven't seen it back yet
[Laughter]
i mean i had a few cars you know what i
mean and it was there were no mclarens
okay but i had bmw i had a
cadillac veteran friend got in some
trouble his car i was
in trouble tossed in the keys and said
hey you know
just give back when you know when you're
done and you get your stuff back and you
figure your stuff out
well long story short a guy the car
disappears and gets thrown in jail
and so i don't care it's just a car but
here's the thing
that was a waste of energy and time
right that was a waste of money
i could have taken that cadillac sold it
put into bitcoin
and then donated all the bitcoin to
charity if i wanted to
done way better impact than doing what i
did right
and so yeah you can learn these lessons
as you go along
all right so listen up cause snoop's
about to i'm sure your guts hold you too
oh yeah all right you ready this is the
gap when we start
this is the gap as you grow notice how
you grow
and they don't so how do you close the
gap
you got to come back down when you come
back down you lose
so you got to keep going up that's why
closing that gap got to be them
catching up to you and if they don't
catch up you got to leave them behind
all right they don't catch up you got to
leave their asses behind that's it
it's as simple as that you're going to
get out of life what you tolerate if you
tolerate mediocrity
from people in your inner circle don't
expect your life to be one of excellence
you're gonna have chaos in it you are
inviting chaos into it you have a choice
you know these guys can either come up
to you or you can leave them behind
you don't have to go go down to their
level
make sense
you